[Music]
let's go out to Toronto Canada and talk
to Emma hey
Emma hi what's
up um strange um it's like I know all
the people used to date life just mixed
do
what like my virtual and real life just
mixed it kind of did um all through high
school and college when I would date
people would be like oh this is strange
and so hey I'm used to that so it's okay
what's
up uh I'm good um but frustrated which
is why I was calling Let's Do It um and
I wrote down my question because I'm not
sure I would be able to say it otherwise
perfect perfect read it read away so so
my question is basically how do I make
myself do the things that I want and
need to do and uh to explain I'm 33
years old
and up to my mid 20s I was always top of
my class had a full scholarship for my
PhD and I was working on it from morning
to evening I would wake up early go to
the library where I would stay until
closing time then go to a cafe and work
until midnight and I loved it the
library was my home and my community in
my safe space um I then met the
wonderful man who's now my husband and
in the past seven years we got married
moved around a lot and had three sweet
sweet little kids um but my kids are all
in daycare now
um um we just arrived in Canada 5 months
ago so I'm still working on a work visa
um so I have time to complete my PhD and
other stuff um when the kids are not at
home and yet I just don't work like I'm
three years already without a
scholarship my PhD is incomplete it's a
monstrous 600 page research that I'm now
trying to edit down I studied for
teaching certificate last year in order
to get a job but I have one seminar work
left to do in order to get that
certificate and yet I'm procrastinating
on that too um I when my kids are in
school I just sit down to work but I end
up scrolling through Facebook watching
YouTube or cooking and then I get
frustrated myself and avoid that feeling
through scrolling on my phone even in
front of my kids and my
husband I just seem to be in a constant
state of distractability and frustration
and avoidance I lost all
self-respect I'm lonely
my friends and husband have all gone on
to become respectable adults who earn
money who keep on studying and learning
and I'm just stuck in a rck and I just
feel like it's all my fault and that I'm
lazy and
useless so how do I make myself do what
I want and need to do why am I not
letting myself do what I want to do and
how do I give my self- discipline
back you may be one of the bravest
people I've talked to in in a long long
time
thank you and I'll just say this it's
one of my great honors to talk to you
thank
you
man as you described your last uh 10
years it's it's fascinating to me how
you and I so quickly land on very
different pictures
of what strength and accomplishment and
and
um uh awesomeness to sound like a high
school kid uh look
like I've got two phds right so I can
talk from some some some gut knowledge
here okay
yeah in the last seven
years I've written a few
books and it sucks right you got to get
up early and I got two little kids too
so you got to deal with the kids and I'm
married and I got a job and then you
write in the night time you WR on the
weekends and all
that Emma you grew three human
beings and you kept them
alive yeah but that's supposed to be the
basic to stay there where in bloody hell
did you get the
story that some arbitrary academic
certificate was of more more Global
importance more accomplishment and
achievement because it's not about the
accomplishment I love the learning I
love the research I love the study okay
but I love it when I do it do you love
it or did you love it no I still do
whenever I managed to make myself sit
down and work I just remember every time
why I love doing it and for some reason
the next day again I can't repeat that
trick
it's just beautiful I mean I'm working
on something so interesting and
fascinating in you and and I just that's
why it's got to be 600 pages I explored
every single aspect of it I
know but you're a different person s
years later
Emma but I can't stop now that's not
true it is it's absolutely not true and
here's how I know that for a fact
I'm one course short from something I've
never talked about this publicly one
course I've had an incomplete for going
on five years
now every semester I email the professor
and say can I get this thing knocked out
and she responds absolutely waiting on
you and I don't do
it and it occurred to me
recently my life has moved
on now I'm stubborn as a mule I'm going
to go grind it out so I can get this
thing
done and here's what's crazy I'll never
talk about it no one no one in my
world's going to know about it my wife
might but my life has changed I have
different priorities and different
values
now and if I have an like a weekend I
got really sick this past weekend and I
read an entire book and then a half of
another one oh my gosh I loved it it was
Heavenly right I had my highlighter out
I read I laid in bed I would fall asleep
I'd wake up and read some more I took
tons of
notes and that's not my life
anymore and I can grieve that's not my
life
anymore give me something I don't want
to grieve this one I want to live this
one but you I feel like you're at war
with your body I am but I want it so
badly okay so let's take let's take
another track here what if your body's
right what if it's right but but it's
not just the PHD it's practically
everything I need to do what is that
it's when we first arrived and I had to
take care of getting my paperwork for my
permanent residency that's my husband
helped me take care of that paperwork
money everything okay but have you given
yourself to do in adult life where's
Home not just my PhD where's
Home not Canada okay far
away
yeah will you give your body a
minute it doesn't even know the air it's
breathing or the ground it's walking on
can't really you know I'm 33 years old
be
I've not lived for longer than four
years in one place in my
life I come always moving I've actually
only lived twice for four years in one
place it's not going to change we're
here only for 3 years
okay well here's what I'm telling you as
directly as I can cuz I love
you you're going to keep hammering away
and I did it I'm I am 10 years ahead of
you or 15 years ahead of you I did
it my body said
stop then I had a kid that we lost a lot
of pregnancies and we had another kid
and my body said dude stop for a
second and I
didn't and I almost lost everything
Emma how did you make yourself do
it
if I had to do it over again I would
have done it very very
differently how I would have
relaxed I would have taken what way how
I would have honored the season I'm in
you're 33 years
old I mean this with all due respect but
you're just getting
started I didn't start my second PhD
till I was 35 my mom didn't start hers
until she was
42 you got three little kids in daycare
you're in a whole new country you're
unable to work the government won't even
let you
work yeah but I don't want to be
spending my days just scrolling through
Facebook or listening to YouTube 1
million per. I got you on that one
you're right on
that the only way I found the only way I
found success there is to be
Draconian to turn screens off give
passwords to somebody that I care
about get rid of them delete everything
off of them which is tough if you move
countries because that's your Lifeline
right
yeah me and so I want you to look at
your
brain as recognizing it is lonely and as
scared as it has ever been and this
magic little box is giving you a life
line to your former
life yeah and like heroin it needs just
a little drip
please this isn't some big Cosmic moral
failure on your
part this is your body trying to
adjust okay yeah
although with the news these days I know
I know that doesn't do anyone any good
either but can you solve
that yeah I guess I got to be dra
Draconian as you said no is there
anything Emma can do in Canada with
three
kids to solve some political challenges
back
home no but I can be helpful
here there are some things I can do to
help from here more importantly than
that there's some things you can do you
can get to know your
neighbors you can make the suburbs quiet
and empty and is no one on the street
there's not but if you go put flyers in
people's doors and say I'm having coffee
at my house every morning at six o'clock
somebody will show
up doesn't look like it's snowing
outside I know I know and that's the
story that's the
loop that's what anxiety and depression
do to us hun and I'm not diagnosing you
I'm not saying that's what happens but
your brain starts to tell stories that
this is the way it's always going to be
it's the way it's always
been
and then you go through the world
looking for what you want to find and
what you're finding right now because it
justifies the story that you're not
enough and you're not going to make it
and you're going to quit just like
everybody else and you are grieving your
old life the life that was 247 dedicated
to her academics learning coming up with
new ideas having late night coffee shop
conversations and that's ju to POS with
hey ma hey Ma can I get a snack can I
get a snack can I get a snack hurry
let's go kids hey hurry hurry do you
have you have your shirt you have your
socks right
yeah in no way are you broken do you
need infinite less screen time
absolutely but I want you to go back and
listen to this
call as painful as it is to say this out
loud every time I've put something on
the table you instantly have a response
for
it and what that means is your world has
gotten increasingly small smaller and
smaller and smaller and your grip on
things has become so tight that even
light and joy and peace can't get
in I don't know how to let go I
know if I give you some really tiny
trite things you promise you'll try them
yeah it's not going to sound like what
you it's not going to be what you want
me to tell
you okay you promise yeah I promise
okay you were been married seven years
so it was
26 27 when you left wherever you
were started having
babies well we've been we moved around
four times since we got married but we
moved country only five months ago okay
I want you to write yourself a
letter to Emma on her on her wedding
night yeah
and I want you to let that naive
wonderful brilliant young woman off the
hook cuz she didn't know what the next
seven years were going to look like four
moves multiple countries three
children and I want you to write her a
letter that says hey I I love you and I
know that you're walking on the aisle
with this man that you love who's a
great guy whatever
whatever and that you think things are
just going to go as they were
everything's about to change and that's
okay and I want that to be a lengthy
letter that you spend some time on and I
want you to promise me that you're going
to start a daily journaling
practice period okay okay and it starts
with dear
Emma good
morning I love
you I know it sounds
silly number three I want you to begin
to look in the mirror in the morning and
I want you to make a fist when nobody's
in the bathroom and I know as a mom of
three small kids that's almost never
right but I want you to tell your
husband I get private bathroom
minutes and I want you to stand in front
of the mirror and put a fist in your
chest and say I love this
girl and I want you to repeat that five
or ten
times okay okay m
the fourth thing is your mission your
singular
mission is to find a friend an in-person
human that you can do life
with whether that's going to coffee
shops whether that's enrolling in a
local class that's separate from your
PhD just to go meet
people the worst part about the
dissertation process is there's no more
deadlines it just is yeah yeah that is
the wor and so I think there could be
some real benefit to signing up for a
class or a course that has a deadline to
it that has people in it that you show
up and you meet and you say
hello and if that fire starts to slowly
um spark up again that's amazing that's
awesome and if you find I just don't
want
to okay yeah but you've got to find
people the last thing I'm going to tell
you to do
is you have to make daily movement a
part of your life which is very hard in
freezing Tundra of Canada in the
winter yeah used to run I can't get
myself out of the house now I
know the do you have the seasonal lights
in your home right
now what is this want you to you have
Amazon there I'm
certain yeah okay I want you to get on
Amazon and I want you to get two or
three light boxes
okay for Seasonal effective disorder
sads when it gets very loud and very
cold I mean I'm sorry not very loud when
it gets very dark and very
cold your whole body starts to shut
down and turning on very bright lights
in the morning has an extraordinary
outside psychological impact a
neurological impact that changes your
brain chemistry
okay every morning I start my day by
going down in my basement and flipping
on some of the craziest Bright Lights
you've ever seen in your
life Wow and that's only if I can't get
outside and see see natural sunlight
okay I can't go down to my basement it's
too dark here that's fine cold if you
get those bright lights and you get them
cranking in your house and your husband
and your kids are going to be like what
are you doing and you're going to smile
and say I'm bringing the Sun to the
bedroom I mean into our bedroom into our
into our living room
right yeah okay
here's what we're looking for I want you
to keep this in your soul write this in
your Journal little
wins okay little
wins and if that means I'm going to edit
one page on my dissertation I want you
to have give yourself a few weeks before
you get back into that I'm G to edit one
page and then I'm putting this
down oh but I got on such a rooll and I
don't care one
page yeah then the next do another
page is that is that fair
yeah most of all I want you to reall in
love with the woman you used to be in
love with which was you you loved the
life you built for yourself you loved
the adventure you were on you loved your
research you loved
Emma and I think you love your husband
right yeah you love your kids you love
your kids right yeah they're amazing
okay what you don't love is the life you
have
yeah I want you to find little glimpses
of feeling alive
again okay you're going to finish the
dissertation I got no question no
question about it I want to tell you
though on the other side of it you're
going to get the graduation you're going
to get the new name you're going to be
Dr Emma it's going to be
awesome and your kid's going to walk in
and go can I have a snack I don't have
any
underwear and you're going to realize
life just keeps going on and I promise
you this cuz I've done it
twice and that's with every great
achievement a number one
book the best financial year of your
life all those things you end up the
person in the mirror the next morning
too hang on the line them I'm going to
send you a copy of building a
non-anxious life it's me my gift to you
you to read it we'll send it up there to
Canada for you you call anytime we're
I'm walking with
you I 1,000% believe in
you